on va parler maintenant un petit peu des
ordonnances sur la loi travail alors est
ce la victoire finale en tout cas c'est
la dernière victoire pour le nouveau
code du travail
la ratification des ordonnances et
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée est
l'aboutissement de la première grande
réforme sociale du quinquennat est ce le
symbole de l'échec des oppositions
qu'elle soit syndicales ou de la france
insoumise un échec c'est évidemment pas
l'avis ni de jean claude mailly le
secrétaire général de force ouvrière
need alexis corbière député de la france
a soumises qui étaient tous les deux des
invités de rtl et europe 1 ce matin on
les écoutait en victoire je ne dirais
pas ça puisque le dossier tel qu'il sort
n'est pas celui qui était envisagé au
début alors maintenant il a réussi à
faire une réforme du code du travail
comme il l'avait annoncé maintenant oui
la fusion des institutions
représentatives du personnel ça va poser
de nombreux de nombreux problèmes c'est
un échec pour je prends de 18 millions
de salariés 1
franchement le jeu ne se sont pas
mobilisés pour le oui mais qui n'ont
désormais celle d'un grand enthousiasme
non plus chaque fois que des études
d'opinion ont été faites je crois qu'il
ya dans cette histoire en mauvais coups
qui est portée contre peu plus france à
ils sont mauvais perdant c'est à dire
oui oui c'est comme une victoire
d'emmanuel mâcon il a passé il a passé
sa réforme qui avait suscité énormément
de romance ou françois hollande
une version plus allégée avait pu
susciter énormément de monde sous
françois hollande a il a passé sans trop
de remous c'est incontestablement une
réussite il a pour lui aussi c'est vrai
que françois hollande a préparé le
terrain de tuer d'accoutumée à ces idées
là et puis surtout en fait toutes les
manifestations de 2016 ont usé mais
c'est en train de syndicale des
militants et c'est donc lui il est
arrivé avec un pacte voilà des militants
qui avaient plus de courage repartir sur
des mois de manifestations font pas
grand chose donc ça aussi hollande lui a
préparé le terrain en fait